uh what'd you do for the fights chin did
you do anything oh yeah just went to
palm springs
is great oh it's cool yeah pretty much
it's three of our friends birthdays the
same
in march march is like a big birthday
month for us too so we just had a bunch
of
bunch of friends over and watch the
fight were they actual fight fans were
they talking like
during the whole they're talking oh
there's nothing worse but we also did
some other stuff too like what like what
just stuff like what drugs
drugs is that that right there's some
drugs so the thing is we have like a
very very close-knit
group of friends right you know each
other for 20-plus years sure so
every now and then we have a
get-together like this we kind of just
want to
you know feel the love feel the love
what do you mean
you had a
you talk about love look we all might
have taken something they helped you
feel the love and we all just
got together what did you guys do you
guys like you can guess it you were high
up during the fight you guys are like
he said we could guess it you can guess
no i'm not trying to watch
oh wow so all the homies is out here
cuddling we're all we're all super close
all asians we're all super cool we're
also close all all asians all asian well
yeah all these all these are cuddling
that guy who'll go with you get your lip
pierced was he there
yeah what's he there he's got a whole
head he's got a whole family
imagine you being with like all your
your close friends i'm not taking it
brings that [ __ ] up in the airbnb on the
road i'm not taking my happy
birthday next week
if you guys want to do it uh let me know
because we know where the
quality stuff is no i don't know
interesting yeah i'm good all right
all right let's be down hard unless
you're awesome [ __ ] no hard drives
no hard pass i'm steve you i'm trying to
think of our crew stevie would be down
i feel like justin i could talk justin
into it jay might be into it that's
three that's a party
and then you [ __ ] can watch on the
sidelines so yeah i was yeah well
you're not watching this cuddle puddle
we're already seeing the cuddle puddle
like i watched it and i know chin once
she said
you do some [ __ ] some cuddling it's just
it's just a really nice loving
mouth am i right that's not enough
am i right chin no a mouth it was six
yeah i thought there was only uh three
couples no no just three people
it was their birthdays but all of our
friends came out
so you all had a twenty person cuddle
puppy we weren't like we were just like
you know love you love you love you
are you alone boba's flying
you guys ever have a chance to do it
barbecue you're popping that night
molly turns gotta try it you gotta try a
weekend for chin yeah chin gets a few
days off
molly [ __ ] during the fights i didn't
say what it was
ching is wild man i saw those pictures
she was bringing up you didn't invite
cat or nobody
that you guys are new you're not
inviting me
plus i know you guys already having the
watch party at your place though i
didn't go you didn't know what i was
doing i thought you guys were all going
there love you
love you and then we just hug each other
all right man
that's the best i feel like they did
more but jim won't say [ __ ] of course
bro
listen you know bro shawty
that's a sexual environment though this
is like just a loving family you guys
said ufc
fights yeah have you seen joe rogan
you and jay should do this by the way
what just like a bunch of you
no close friends no we need girls dude
yeah my girlfriend was there but i mean
just
with your girls just have like a you
know because everyone's close in your
family right
pretty close you'd get weird if i was
high it's not
that way though it's just really chin
it's nice what's the [ __ ]
i don't know it's funny you guys aren't
open-minded yeah i gotta be open-minded
i'm with chin and cat well the three of
us would do it no you you keep saying
that but when you see like dudes kissing
dudes and girls
i don't give a [ __ ] but it's a rise
right i don't care if dude's kissing
them i don't give a [ __ ] he's not like
trying to get one puddle bro okay all
right you feel good for them you know
that's that's lovely that's right
i literally wouldn't listen i wouldn't
be like oh good for hillary all right
dude
y'all y'all was strictly based off the
emotion of love
love friendship friendship friendship
love yeah we all
we knew each other for how long over 20
years did you get that guitar
right get there's too much music in the
background you're not gonna hear the
guitar
when the beat drops and you guys were
there friday saturday
friday i was there friday and saturday
they stayed until like sunday wow
what a weekend for china right
finally did something well i'm just
saying like usually it's a junior oh
yeah it's a go ahead murdering fish
like you actually did [ __ ] yeah yeah you
you went outside the box that's what you
did yeah
there's a pool there too oh
palm springs is a warm area so yeah palm
springs is great my boy lives there man
it went up though it's like a million
dollars a house out it's been like that
yeah seriously yeah
palm springs always expensive oh damn
chad
chin all right how about that when i get
off stage with the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son